sí pues aquí continúa continúan todavía
contando ya han anunciado además como
has dicho que seguirán el conteo hasta
el 12 de noviembre además aún continúen
aquí en una especie de limbo electoral y
cada voto que se gana a favor o en
contra de trampa a favor de trump está
siendo contado y se vive bueno pues eso
estamos como si fuese un limbo electoral
todos los ojos están puestos ahora en
este estado donde el margen de
diferencia entre bailén y trump continúa
siendo estrechísimo vaivén todavía
lidera con el 49 por ciento y trump
sigue con el 48 por ciento un margen que
se ha ampliado muy levemente hoy después
de un recuento inicial esta mañana a las
nueve de la mañana en el que bardem ha
sacado cuatro mil votos más lo que les
sitúa con once mil votos por ahora por
delante de trump como digo un margen
estrechísimo esta mañana oficiales del
condado de clark de donde donde está
situado las vegas anunciaron que están
contando más de 60.000 votos ahora cuyo
anuncio pueden hacer en menos de una
hora
susana donald trump ha puesto una
demanda verdad contra el condado para
que detengan el conteo de los votos
contanos qué repercusiones ha tenido lo
que sucede con esto
sí así es la campaña de trampa asegura
que muchos de estos votos son ilegales y
que también muchos de estos votos han
sido emitidos al parecer por personas ya
fallecidas los oficiales del condado de
clark han asegurado que seguirá el
conteo hasta que al menos reciban
instrucciones de ayer por la noche si
hubo protestas frente a uno de los
centros electorales donde se está
realizando este conteo había gente a
favor de trump que pedían también que se
pare este conteo ya había también gente
que protestaba a favor de bailén para
que continúe este conteo como digo está
siendo un drama electoral aquí en nevada